[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition de votre journal d'information
locale voici les principaux titres en
images comme toujours de ce 16 février
2017 ce sera bientôt officier la ville
de khobar en palestine va être jumelée
avec celle de la verrière un choix
politique les explications de la mère
d'études en un instant et défis
scientifiques et techniques les trophées
de robotique propose à des équipes de
jeunes de créer un robot filoguidé la
finale régionale se déroule à montigny
le bretonneux ce week end
et puis top départ à biarritz de la 20e
édition du 4l trophy une aventure
humaine sportive et humanitaire qui
rassemble cette année près de deux mille
neuf cents participants ils ont entre 18
et 28 ans et parmi eux des saint
quentinois forcément il n'y aura pas
pour l'instant de classement sans suite
de l affaire des emplois présumés
fictifs de l épouser des enfants de
françois fillon le parquet financier l'a
fait savoir ce jeudi matin dans un
communiqué ambiance toujours morose donc
pour les militants et pourtant ils sont
toujours sur le terrain et nous sommes
avec suzanne blanc et lui les
républicains à montigny le bretonneux
soutien de la première heure à françois
fillon bonsoir suzanne blanc vous êtes
en ce moment même en pleine opération de
distribution de tracts avec les
militants c'est en gare de saint quentin
en yvelines
comment vous avez reçu perçu cette
annonce ce matin du parquet sur cette
affaire des emplois fictifs
oui monsieur richie bonsoir bien écouter
qu'il y suit ensuite dit sans poursuites
en tout cas donc nous nous continuons
nous voulons surtout faire entendre le
programme de françois fillon qu'on
arrête un peu avec cet acharnement de
toutes les minutes sur toutes les radios
et chaînes nationales et voilà on est là
pour distribuer la lettre de françois
fillon à ses concitoyens et c'est ce
qu'on on est en train de faire on est
quelques-uns malko les vacances donc
voilà on a choisi effectivement d'être
sur le terrain d'expliquer si besoin
françois villon de ne pas justement
sombrer dans la morosité et aucune
raison justement françois fillon est
désormais crédité
de 17,5 à 18,5 pour cent des intentions
de vote selon différentes hypothèses
il recule tout de même c'est ce qui est
significative significatif de 6,5 points
en un mois plus de 10 points depuis sa
victoire à la primaire de la droite et
du centre
comment vous allez réussir sur le
terrain inverser la tendance avec un
accueil qui parfois je l'imaginé est un
peu frileux sur le terrain oui ça peut
bien sûr être un peu frileuse tous les
temps comme je vous le disais à
l'instant nous sommes là pour expliquer
le programme de françois fillon le
défendre bien sûr et puis bien coûter à
coeur vaillant rien d'impossible
et donc par conséquent on va se battre
et puis peut-être que dans un mois il y
aura des surprises
pourquoi la des surprises dans le bon
sens par rapport aux sondages que l'on
entend aujourd'hui par ailleurs par
rapport à certaines annonces qu'il a
faites il hier soir à son meeting de
compiègne moi ce que j'ai entendu
aujourd'hui c'est que 80% des français
étaient favorables à ce qu'il avait
proposé il est re soir pas plus tard que
hier soir donc voyez il n'y a pas non
plus que des gens dans la morosité il ya
aussi des gens qui croient en lui en son
programme merci suzanne blonde avoir été
en ligne avec nous je rappelle que vous
êtes en direct en ce moment en pleine
opération de distribution de tracts
justement pour cette campagne de
françois fillon sur le terrain merci à
vous dans l'actualité de ce jeudi
également à l' annonce de la signature
prochaine d'un jumelage entre la ville
de la verrière et celle de khobar c'est
un village de palestine proche de
ramallah en cisjordanie
un jumelage qui marque selon la mairie
selon la mère pardon de cette commune
une volonté de contribuer à la paix
écoutez là c'est au micro de semaine
vendeurs de la palestine ça fait
soixante ans que les apatrides les
palestiniens c'est fin c'est
inconcevable de
moi-même j'imagine pas que pourrait
vivre un jour sans nationalité quoi donc
ça me semble être le droit élémentaire
d'un individu que d'être de quelque part
donc ça on ne porte depuis toujours sept
sont des valeurs tout bêtement humaine
tout fin du droit de tout un chacun et
une délégation de cette ville de khobar
se rendra à la verrière au cours de la
semaine prochaine
on quitte la politique à présent pour
l'édition 2010 cette aide des trophées
de robotique c'est une compétition
réservée aux 7 18 ans ils doivent
concevoir construire un robot filoguidé
en un temps record ce samedi ce sera l
étape régionale pour l'île de france ce
sera à montigny le bretonneux à saint
quentin en yvelines
nous avons assisté à l'entraînement
d'une des équipes de saint quentin cet
attrape anne-laure l'anguille
voici le robot construit par cette jeune
habitant de trappes l'engin filoguidé a
nécessité plus de quatre mois de travail
ses auteurs goûte aujourd'hui le plaisir
de l'eau conduire
ces enfants du centre socioculturel
annette moreau de trappes participent
aux trophées de la robotique organisé
par l'association planète sciences ils
s'entraînent en vue de la finale
régionale qui opposera ce samedi une
quarantaine d'équipés à montigny le
bretonneux laventure a ravi tous les
participants qui peuvent compter sur le
soutien indéfectible de leurs parents en
fait à construire va complètement à
partir juste quelques électrique d'un
moteur et de plein d'autres choses et
pour moi construire un robot le
manipulait tout ça c'est j'aime bien
c'est bien c'est la famille est choquant
c'est c'est eh mais la petite boule de
positionnement lettre l'expérience
semble avoir inspiré à ces petites têtes
de grandes ambitions
ingénieur en robotique à l'issue de la
compétition les équipes gagnantes
participeront à la finale nationale les
1er et 2 avril prochains
celle ci en fera partie sans aucun doute
l'emporté lors de ce trophée de
robotique du futur nous vous faisons
maintenant un voyage vers le passé à
magny les hameaux l'église du village a
obtenu le titre de monument historique
cela faisait deux ans que la ville
attendait cette inscription une partie
seulement de ce site avait déjà été
classée 7 et en 1935 et découverte de ce
patrimoine avec camille lambert
[Musique]
cet hôtel est absolument exceptionnel
parce que vous n'en avez pas
d'équivalent le dire pour le nord le
nord au nord de la loire
généralement au 17e c'est plutôt des
hôtels avec des peintures ici on a un
hôtel de stuc
les villageois ont gardé l'hôtel tel
qu'il était à la fin du xviie siècle il
n'ya plus d'équivalent dans les églises
de l'île de france aujourd'hui
cet hôtel c'est l'un des joyaux de
l'église saint germain de paris qui lui
a valu son inscription au titre de
monument historique
une reconnaissance pour cet édifice du
12e siècle
magny les hameaux a oeuvré de 2002 à
2009 pour sa restauration coût total des
travaux 950 mille euros financé à 80 %
par la ville
beaucoup d'habitants tenait à ce que ce
ce lieu cette église soit préservée et
puis effectivement qu'on puisse avoir
une histoire la grande histoire de port
royal des champs et de magny les hameaux
côte-à-côte obtenu en novembre cette
distinction permettra de conserver au
mieux la mémoire locale
ce qui fait l'immense richesse de
l'église aujourd'hui à manille c'est
qu'elle conserve une quarantaine de
pierres tombales c'est la plus grosse
collection de tout le nord de la loire
dont 40 pierre tombale entre le xiiie
siècle et le xviie siècle dont les deux
tiers proviennent de l'abbaye de port
royal
autre découverte ce tableau du xviie
siècle du peintre italien guido reni
saint jérôme au désert une seule
réplique existe la national gallery de
londres
l'église du village n'a pas fini de
dévoiler tous ses secrets
culture et cette nouveauté pour cette
année le tremplin musical de plaisir
auparavant des 10 uniquement aux jeunes
du lycée jean vilar s'adresse désormais
à tous les jeunes talents de la
communauté d'agglomération à saint
quentin en yvelines
les inscriptions se terminent le 10 mars
et non le 22 février comme cela avait
été annoncé
amateurs soliste ou en groupe les
participants sont invités à faire
découvrir leur musique leurs
compositions lors d'une soirée et le
public votera ce sera le 6 mai à la clé
des champs en équipe on écoute la
directrice des affaires culturelles de
la ville qui a trois catégories pour
cette scène tremplin il ya une catégorie
musique solo ou en groupe avec vraiment
toutes les couleurs musicales chanson
française hip hop dubstep voilà il y à
aussi la catégorie animateur stand-up et
la catégorie dj ce qui est nouveau il
n'y a pas que les grandes enseignes qui
s'illustre dans le domaine de la
décoration vous connaissez peut-être
cette petite enseigne secret d'intérieur
c'est aux clayes-sous-bois elle est
installée depuis maintenant une dizaine
d'années au centre ville et bien elle a
gagné le trophée de la nuit de la déco
organisé en novembre dernier découverte
de cette cave au est trésor avec ce
reportage
vraiment avec tout ça réveille un
manteau noir en autorise même du marron
c'est super joli écharpe colorée bijoux
de créateur ou épiceries fines chez
dominique en ressort rarement les mains
vides
même quand on n'a pas trop d'idées c'est
la saveur matin donc un petit cadeau
pour vos fans vous fait deux ans que je
travaille sur le coin donc c'est à côté
du boulot cette pratique
je trouve toujours quelque chose
difficile de ne pas trouver son bonheur
parmi les 70 fournisseurs qui se trouve
dans la boutique
dominique a monté son affaire il y a dix
ans et une consécration cette année fin
janvier elle a reçu le trophée de la
nuit de la déco on a fait beaucoup de
buzz on a fait beaucoup d'animations
c'est sur plusieurs jours moi j'ai
choisi de faire une soirée une soirée
complète jusque minuit mais avec de
nombreuses animations
on a beaucoup de mal à communiquer en
fait parce qu'on n'a pas les budgets des
grandes chaînes de magasins et la nuit
de la déco c'est vraiment fait pour ça
c'est pour donner une visibilité aux
petites boutiques de proximité pour
cette première participation plus de 250
internautes ont voté pour secret
d'intérieur parmi une centaine de
magasins une opération de communication
mais surtout solidaire on vend des dvd
piqueur pour au profit de mécénat
chirurgie cardiaque
donc ça c'était vraiment aussi très très
bien et qui en partant bien participer
puisque j'ai pu récolter 600 euros pour
mécénat chirurgie cardiaque et boutiques
comme moi je t'ai j'étais assez fier et
on remet ça puisque le 19 mai on refait
une nuit de la déco et là ça va être sur
le thème
les boutiques pour leur cinéma le
magasin affiche aujourd'hui un chiffre
d'affaires de 250 mille euros par an ce
trophée permet une reconnaissance
supplémentaire dans un secteur dominé
par les grandes enseignes sport à
présent et cette mauvaise nouvelle
l'annulation du gala de boxe l encours
par les organisateurs le rendez-vous
était programmé le 11 mars il devait
réunir deux grandes la tête d'affiche
française de la discipline dont les
boxeurs locaux est d'elancourt marvin
petit double champion de france ou adil
hamouma dit champion d'europe des poids
super moyens on écoute leur coach temps
guy farrugia nous l'avons joint par
téléphone l'on doit le promoteur et les
frileux et la prépa le plein chez nous à
l eau qu il aime bien partout où il va
faire le plan parce que partout il
organise depuis le flanc il a peur de
mon après la chute de son cours pour que
des sites qui puisse l'aider à organiser
et et pour l'instant aucune nouvelle
date n'a été communiquée pour ce nouveau
prochain gala elle en cours et puis une
image pour refermer ce journal
le départ de la 20e édition du 4l trophy
c'était aujourd'hui pour une centaine d'
yvelinois qui y participent
le coup d'envoi de cette course 100%
étudiante a été donné à midi ce jeudi
depuis le village de départ installé à
biarritz au programme six mille
kilomètres à travers la france l'espagne
le maroc jusqu'au 26 février
objectif de cette course réalisé le
moins de kilomètres possible pour
remporter la victoire et en parallèle
les quelques mille quatre cent cinquante
équipages feront également une bonne
action ils vont distribuer des
fournitures scolaires aux enfants
africains l arrivée est prévue le 26
février juste avant le début donc des
partielles pour la plupart des étudiants
des écoles engagées
je vous retrouve demain vendredi pour
une nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'hebdo le
journal revient quant à lui à lundi tous
nos programmes sont à retrouver en
replay sur notre site internet et sur
vos portables et tablettes avec notre
application mobile à bientôt
[Musique]